mark german has just given us a massive
amount of new information
on a variety of apple silicon macs
including
the 14 and 16 inch macbook pros
which he says are coming this summer so
yeah if you watch my video where i bet
my goatee
once again on a wwdc reveal of these new
m1x macbook pros
you'll know why i'm so excited about it
but it doesn't stop there because he's
also given us new info
on the new macbook air redesign the
apple silicon mac pro
the mac mini and apparently the new 10
core m1x chip
which is definitely a huge surprise but
i've actually figured out why this new
chip makes
so much sense for apple to do so let's
get right into that first
for many months we believe that the m1x
chip would come with
12 cpu cores based on information from
mark german
who claimed that we would be getting
eight high performance cores
in the next apple silicon chip so we
rightfully assumed that those eight
cores would combine
with the existing four efficiency cores
that we already have
to give us a 12 core m1x chip
which would end up blowing everyone's
mind but
we were wrong the new 10 court ship is
actually gonna be
better than what we thought it would be
and if you think that's
absolutely crazy let me explain the bulk
of the performance
is going to be coming from those eight
performance cores
so losing two efficiency cores isn't
going to be that big of a deal
especially since apple is planning to
use the now freed up space
for something even better apple's m1 soc
package comes with various components
like the processing cores
the graphics cores the neural engine
unified memory
and everything else if apple plans to
add four more performance cores
they're gonna likely need to make the
entire silicon die larger
regardless of whether they get rid of
those two efficiency cores or not
since i'm expecting them to reuse the
same exact m1 cores
from their current max and the issue is
that making the entire die
size larger becomes more expensive and
harder to manufacture
so it seems like apple is ditching two
of those efficiency cores
to make more room for some higher
performance components
specifically mark german says that we'll
be getting up to 64 gigabytes of memory
an improved neural engine and either a
16 or 32 core gpu
so let me break all of that down and
explain what that's going to mean for
you
first off a maximum of 64 gigs of ram
makes sense because that's the current
limit on the 16-inch intel based macbook
pro
so apple seems to want to match it with
the new 16-inch m1x model and as you
guys already know from our videos
apple's unified memory is incredibly
efficient compared to regular old x86
ram
which more easily bottlenecks the
performance of the system
so in my opinion the base 16 gigabyte of
ram
variant on the m1x is going to be more
than enough for almost
everyone out there now as far as the
neural engine an
upgraded model makes sense and it's
going to be a huge deal in the future
especially looking at how much it helped
the m1 macbook air
in an ai based super resolution test
compared to samsung's new galaxy book
pro now going further
mark also mentioned that we're getting
more thunderbolt ports which makes total
sense
so probably either three or four of them
according to leaked schematics
and i'm sure that it's going to support
the same number of displays
as the current intel macbook pros and
now moving on to the graphics
this is what's going to truly blow all
of you away
german says that there will be two
separate chips codenamed
jade c chop and c die one with a 16 core
gpu
and one with 32 cores now i know that
some people online
think that this means that the gpu will
be discrete
and separated from the main chip but
that's wrong
the m1x will be combined into one
single package and here's how apple is
gonna do it
if you take a look at the current m1
chip the unified memory is actually off
to the
side allowing apple to configure it with
either eight gigs or 16 gigs of ram
and there were actually some people who
were able to unsolder the ram
and upgrade it themselves so to solve
the gpu option issue
on the m1x there are actually two
different ways that apple can handle
this
the first way is by doing exactly what
they did with the ram
by attaching the graphics onto the other
side of the chip
in the same manner allowing apple to
configure the
m1x with either a 16 or 32 core gpu
however if apple uses the same exact gpu
cores
from the m1 chip then they wouldn't be
able to fit
32 cores in the same area as
16 cores so the actual package
would undoubtedly have to be larger for
the 32 core variant
because of this i think the second way
makes much more sense
just like mark german said there's gonna
be two separate chips
one with 16 graphics cores that supports
up to 32 gigs of ram
and another physically larger chip with
32 graphics cores
that supports up to 64 gigs of ram
forcing you to upgrade to the larger
chip if you want
all of that ram the only question that's
left unanswered
is whether they'll call both variants
the m1x chip
or maybe mixing it up by calling it the
m1x and
the m1z but i personally think it's
gonna be
the m1x for both but the more important
thing is the performance of those gpus
so let's quickly discuss that when i
estimated the performance of the 16 core
m1x a couple of months ago
we basically confirmed that it would
outperform
the crazy expensive 800 5600
m upgrade on the current 16-inch macbook
pro
which is absolutely insane so if the m1x
actually gets a 32 core gpu option
like mark german says it will we're
looking at graphics performance getting
close to as high
as the vega 2 gpu within the intel based
mac pro
and i have a pretty good feeling that
it's actually going to be faster in
terms of
real-world workflows due to the unified
architecture
but going beyond that some people are
worried that the whole
10 core layout with only two efficiency
cores
is going to be bad for the battery life
but let me explain why i think it's not
going to be an issue
in linus tech tips review of the new m1
macbooks
the air lasted about 13 hours in their
real world
battery life test compared to over 20
hours
for the macbook pro that comes out to
around 53 percent
better battery life which is
mind-blowing because the battery on the
macbook pro
is only around 16 larger than the one
on the macbook air so what this proves
is that the extra 16
in physical battery size was able to
take
the real world battery life a lot
further than expected
so if we consider the fact that the
current 16-inch macbook pro
comes with a 100 watt hour battery
literally twice as large as the one in
the macbook air
i think the battery life on the m1x
16-inch model
is gonna be totally great even with only
two efficiency cores
and according to mark german the 14 and
16 inch pros are both coming
this summer which points to apple
revealing them at their wwdc event
less than three weeks from today so now
with the macbook pros out of the way
let's go ahead and look at the other
products like the new mac mini
which german says will be getting the
same m1x chip options as the macbook
pros
and now it makes total sense why apple
went with only two efficiency cores
since the desktop mac mini doesn't
really need them and that is why
i personally believe that apple will
reveal the new mac mini
alongside the new macbook for a summer
launch
since that's exactly what they did last
november with the m1 max
but i don't know when it's gonna ship
especially since mark said that it could
get delayed but based on everything that
mark said
i fully expect the current m1 mac mini
to stick around
at the same 700 price and then the new
m1x mini
will directly replace the current intel
base model
so you're going to have a choice between
the m1 and the m1x mini and based on all
of that info
and the potential for the m1x chip to
get a 32 core gpu
i fully believe that this same m1x chip
is going to be loaded into the larger
30 inch imac when they reveal that later
this year at another event most likely
in october or
november now as far as the new
redesigned macbook air that we've been
discussing for a while
mark says that it's going to be packed
with a chip that's going to be a direct
successor to the m1 processor which
obviously means
that it's going to be called the m2 chip
with the same number of
cpu cores but they're going to be new
cores
so they're going to be faster the only
surprise that mark gave us
was that the graphics cores will
increase from seven or eight
to nine or ten so basically you're
getting two more graphics cores
based on the model that you're going to
be choosing mark also mentioned that the
lower end base
1300 macbook pro would be getting the
exact same chip
as the new air and i personally believe
that both of them are going to be
revealed
at the same time now mark says that the
air could come as soon as the end of
this year
but i think it could get pushed back
into march of 2022
based on rumors from ming chi quo and
digitimes
now as far as the mac pro mark gave us
some more info on that
now claiming that it's going to look
like a smaller version of the current
mac pro design basically you turning
on his previous claim that it's going to
look like a much taller mac mini
and i think that this makes total sense
because the design of the mac pro
has kind of become iconic and it makes
sense to keep it around
but the mind-blowing thing is that he
says it's going to come with either a 20
or
40 core cpu and either a 64
or 128 core gpu and i personally think
that it's going to be coming sometime
next year most likely in december but
before that happens
we should totally be expecting just one
more intel based
mac pro refresh at the end of this year
in december
using the same exact chassis that we
currently have
but packing new intel xeon iceland chips
and big navi graphics options so there
you guys go
those are my thoughts on mark's latest
report and if you totally disagree with
me
go ahead and comment your thoughts down
below but if you enjoyed the video go
ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe
for more videos like this one definitely
check out one of those two right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video